من وقت ما ضرب الزلزال المدمر سوريا
وتركيا ولد نوع من الخوف والهلع عند اغلب
العالم وصار اي اشاره من الطبيعه كفيله
انه تقلب الدنيا وتعمل حاله رعب وفي لبنان
ومصر شايفين الايام الماضيه المنصات
مقلوبه بالصور ومقاطع بتتكلم عن انحصار
مياه البحر وموجات تسونامي جايه وعلاقه
بين هذا وزلزال تركيا وسوريا في لبنان وفي
منطقه عدلون نشرت الناس صور وفيديوهات
لمستويات البحر وهي متراجعه وكمان معاها
صور لتصدعات في صخور على الشواطئ
جماعه الخير البحر امين عدلون لا يزال
صارت المي
الله يستر
في مصر صار نفس الكلام والناس اتداولت صور
من شمال سيناء الانحصار البحر وقالوا انه
تراجع عشره و15 متر وانه هذه ظاهره اول
مره بتصير الرعب والخوف اللي سببته هذه
الصور والمقاطع دفع المراكز المختصه فورا
انها ترد وتوضح خاصه لما الناس ربطت
الموضوع بالزلزال وكلام عن تسونامي قادم
المجلس الوطني للبحوث العلميه في لبنان
وضح في بيان انه تراجع مياه البحر مرتبط
علميا بحركه المد هو الجزر واللي قد تكون
اقوى في بعض السنوات وانه الطقس الصافي
وعدم وجود عواصف او امواج جعل ملاحظه وجود
الجزر اكثر وضوحا المجلس صحه انه تراجع
البحر بسبب حتميه وصول امواج تسونامي وفي
مصر كمان المعهد القومي للبحوث الفلكيه
صرح بنفس الكلام تقريبا وهذا توضيح حصري
لنا من الدكتور جاد القاضي رئيس المعهد
اولا من خلال البيانات المعهد يسجلها
وعددات اخرى هيئه حمايه الشواطئ ومعه بحوث
شواطئ المعدلات اللي موجوده لانخفاض منسوب
سطح البحر او تذبذب منسوب سطح البحر دي
معدلات طبيعيه خالص في وقتها لانه احنا في
نهايه الشهر العربي احنا عارفين ان في
علاقه وطيله ما بين القمر والارض بنسميها
المد والجزر فده احد الحيثيات الجزئيه
الثانيه ان على مدار العام في مواسم بيبقى
فيها انخفاض نسبي
واوقات بيكون فيها ارتفاع نسبي فده على
مدار العام
شهر فبراير ومارس من الاواخر بيكون فيها
انخفاض لكن المعدلات المرصوده حاليا مش زي
الارقام اللي بنسمعها 10 و15 متر القصه
كلها يعني لا تتعدى الواحد متر ودي زي ما
قلت لحضراتكم يعني في النطاق الامن
والمسموع الجزء الثاني من الموضوع ده ملوش
علاقه لما يتردد على السوشيال ميديا اذا
كان مرتبط بزلزال بتاع تركيا وان كان في
تحذير في وقت ما من موجات تسونامي او مد
بحري الكلام ده ملوش علاقه تماما بعيد عن
الصحه وعن اي محتوى علمي لهذا لهذه
الظاهره
[موسيقى]